this has always been the problem for me
when i look at like free market right
wing people i go you expect everyone to
pull themselves by their bootstraps
that's not going to happen that's not
that's a lot of them can't that's my
point right lots of them can't because
we understand people have different iqs
and different genetic bases and
different
experiences in childhood and whatever
and on the other hand
you've got people on the left who say
well inequality isn't tolerable and i
agree with that
but as you say the systems that they
trying to apply
in order to address that don't work and
don't make any sense and create terrible
outcomes
so where is the golden middle well
that's
look the reason that i'm an advocate of
free speech
is that the golden middle moves and so
how do we find it
well we talk about it where is it it
moves all the time
yesterday's solution isn't going to work
today it it
so that that golden solution is a
is genuinely a mobile point
because inequality even changes with
time
you know and and the conservative
viewpoint is inadequate i was watching
the crown
and the seasons with maggie thatcher you
know and thatcher
extraordinarily conscientious person
that's her fundamental
attribute and that is a predictor of
conservatism and that's dutifulness
industriousness orderliness
by the book patriotism all of that if
you want someone to run your company
you want a conscientious person if you
want a teacher you want a conscientious
teacher
um it's not associated with artistic
creativity
that's that predicts liberalism that's
openness
in any case mark maggie thatcher is
extremely conscientious and she believes
that
hard work will get you there and and
that should be
encouraged and and everyone can pull
themselves up by their own bootstraps
and
look there's truth in that if you look
at what predicts
people's success across time this is
where psychology is actually reliable
as a science we know some of what
predicts life outcomes and we know it
validly
and reliably so the best predictor is iq
and that accounts for about 25 of the
differences in outcome between people
so a lot's left unexplained right 75 but
25 is a lot the next best predictor is
conscientiousness
and it accounts for about five to nine
percent
which again isn't leaves a lot
unexplained but it's not nothing and
then the third one is
how sensitive you are to negative
emotion and it accounts for something
like three to four percent
um so it is definitely the case that if
you took two people
that are equal in some valuable domain
the one that works harder is going to
do better and that might even compound
over time but if you take
two people of radically different iq and
they both work equally hard the person
with the higher iq is going to crush the
person with
with the lower iq and you know you said
we know that and
and but we don't because you can't even
talk about iq in
modern society it's such a hot topic and
it's not surprising
it's like i know the iq literature for a
variety of reasons partly because i
built tests to predict performance and
and studied that for 15 years
and my tests couldn't sell at least in
part because they actually
worked and were too threatening because
of that well and there's reasons for
that
but if you're
if you have an iq of under 82 you can't
be inducted into the american armed
forces
and the reason for that is the armed
forces have done iq testing for a very
long time
and they're hungry for people always so
they're not going to throw away anybody
that they can
use they found that they couldn't teach
anybody with an iq of
under 82 anything that made them
valuable they were a net drain and
that's 10
of the population
so that's there's about as many people
with an iq of 82 or lower as there are
of people who are capable of doing well
in a
institute of higher education
so and among that population those who
work harder are going to do better
but but in a cognitively complex
environment
they're at a marked disadvantage and can
the conservatives can't deal with that
they don't know what to do about that
and fair enough you know it's like it's
a very hard problem and the liberals
they say
the liberals take the opposite attack
which is even more annoying in my
estimation it's like
well you can train anyone to do anything
and that's
that's so wrong that that it's hard to
even know where to begin
i'd love it if it was the case i'll give
you an example of this
so the americans in their war on poverty
ran a program called head start
and head start was a program that
everyone wanted to succeed conservatives
and liberals alike and so
the idea was get disadvantaged kids
early
and enrich their education say between
the ages of three and five preschool
so the americans poured immense
monetary resources into this project and
and it has been studied in terms of
outcomes
for decades and
its goal was to increase cognitive
performance that was its goal
and it did but did but the differences
went away so the hope was if you got the
kids early and taught them
they'd get they'd develop an advantage
and then that advantage would compound
across time
and it would ameliorate the worst
effects of poverty and who wouldn't want
that right like
i don't care who you are everyone wants
that um
the kids did leap ahead academically but
all the other kids caught up by grade
three or four and then after that
there was no differences at all between
the head start kids and the non-head
start kids
except the head start kids were less
likely to get pregnant and drop out of
school and they were more likely to
graduate
but that looks like it was a
socialization effect
probably some of those kids were
shielded against the worst of their
family environment
by being in daycare but there was zero
effect on cognitive ability
very unfortunate right because because
that was that was a large scale
social experiment everyone had the
highest hopes for it
no effect on cognitive ability what
you're talking about jordan is actually
the great taboo in education
i i was a teacher for many many years
and my my head with the head deputy head
would go to me in the primary school
why is it that you know this cohort
aren't doing as well as last year's
cohort
and it was seen as taboo to just go well
last year's cohort was smarter yeah
no one no one can tolerate iq look it's
the only thing psychologists have ever
discovered
really except for maybe the big five
it's
like these are facts say iq is
unbelievable it's easy to measure
to measure iq all you have to do is take
any
set of questions that require
abstraction to answer
and so you can take 20 questions
you can do that you know better or worse
but with 20 random questions you're
going to get a decent estimate
so take 20 questions ask a hundred
people the answers
sum up the answers rank order the people
that'll be correlated with iq at
something like
0.8.9 really high really high
that's all you have to do and then
that'll be predicted with their life or
that'll predict their life outcomes like
economic
uh economic success for example
that'll account for about 25 percent of
the difference across people it's
unbelievably powerful and it's
unidimensional as well you know you hear
all these
appalling claims that there are multiple
kinds of intelligences and
multiple kinds of learning styles and
skills
look people people differ in their
abilities and they're not all reducible
to iq
but in the in the realm of intellectual
endeavor it's one factor it's one thing
one thing it's not decomposable not not
really
and that's harsh man it's harsh let me
ask this question jordan because i feel
like it's begging to be asked
and you've teased that you've put us in
a position where i have to ask you this
question
uh given the way that you've been
talking about this
and that question is i mean it comes
obviously
what is our fear of this conversation
there is i feel it i sense it as we talk
about this
there is some kind of pandora's box at
the end of this conversation
it um it violates our moral sensibility
you know we we deeply believe that human
beings are of equal value
it's a predicate of well i think it's
probably a predicate of human biology in
some sense but
maybe not but in any case because you
could make a case that we're
aristocratic by nature too but
forget about that certainly it's a
it's the fundamental axiom of the west
everyone's equal before the law we're
all of equal value in that transcendent
sense
okay well what does that mean
practically
well what we hope it means is that
we're sort of roughly equal in ability
or trainability at least
and we're not and no one that doesn't
sit well with us
we don't even know what to do with it
we're very uneasy with it and then it's
no wonder
now ignoring it isn't going to help and
also what also isn't going to help is
you know in boston for example recently
they shut down a lot of the gifted
programs because
the ethnic makeup of the classes was
un unacceptable it wasn't randomly
it wasn't randomly selected let's say
around or it wasn't
uh representative of the broader
community
and it's no wonder that that bothers
people who wouldn't that bother
but what are we going to do in that
situation you shut down the gifted
classes well
who are those gifted classes for are
they for the gifted kids
or are they for society at large
there isn't anything more valuable than
human intelligence
and if we don't utilize it well then we
let it go to waste
well how can that be in anyone's
interest it's a resource that we should
maximally exploit even for our own
narrow self-interest
but we can't and so gifted programs
they're always
people are never happy with them or even
with the idea
you know you can be as you can you can
celebrate differences in athletic
ability
and we certainly do we're very uneasy
when we celebrate differences in
intellectual ability
it's kind of a non-starter it isn't part
of the problem that we don't want to
admit that we all have our limits we
like to pretend that we can go out we
can achieve anything in fact
isn't that the basis of the american
dream but the reality is
we can't and that's not simply the world
that we live in
well this is a nice upbeat conversation
inspiring people all over the world
isn't it
well like like
working hard helps a lot
so hooray i mean there's one example for
example
in general the the offspring of first
generation asian immigrants to the us
outperform the offspring
of americans but also the the
the offspring of second generation
immigrants
why it looks like it's because they work
much harder and they work harder enough
to give them
what's roughly a 15 point iq advantage
equivalent and that's roughly the
difference between a college student
average college graduate say and the
average high school graduate
it's a big difference and it's a big
difference so
so work hard set your sights
you know 60 hour weeks discipline all of
that
no doubt and but you know there
there are pretty pronounced individual
differences in the ability to do that as
well
so even that's a rough
even your ability to focus and
concentrate in a disciplined way
seems to be quite affected by underlying
biological factors
and that's also unjust it appears unjust
in a fundamental way
[Music]